hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es mal wieder etwas
leckeres mediterranes ich mache nämlich
heute gefüllte spitz paprika aus dem
ofen
also das sind diese großen roten schönen
leckeren spitz fabbrica und die habe ich
heute morgen im supermarkt gesehen und
hab gedacht kommen da muss man jetzt ein
rezept dazu machen und ich habe mich
dazu entschieden sie mit couscous zu
füllen und ich zeige euch einfach mal
ganz kurz die zutaten also ich habe hier
diese paprika das sind 500 gramm und
sind einfach sechs stück dann brauche
ich olivenöl eine zwiebel oder so wie
hier eine kleine charlotte ich brauche
couscous das sind 270 gramm und zwar
gibt es couscous so einfach so zu kaufen
im supermarkt und das wird aus
hartweizengrieß hergestellt wenn man
jetzt keinen kuss kuss hat oder was
anderes nehmen möchte die kameras nehmen
oder zum beispiel bürger also wohl gut
geht es ja auch im supermarkt und aber
ich habe mich eure zeit für den couscous
entschieden den kenne ich auch aus
meiner kindheit fähig das holz ein
bisschen dass erinnerungen an die
kindheit dann nehme ich dazu ein paar
schwarze oliven ein paar kleine scharfe
chilis und ich hab hier so'n paprika
passte und zwar ist es auch eine chance
falls ihr den ich bekommt könnt ihr aber
auch zum beispiel einfach bisschen
tomatenmark nehmen oder paprika mark
oder was das kennt man ja auch ganz gut
gibt es auch wenn man so kleinen
gläschen im supermarkt was einfach
irgendwas noch dazu damit man so ein
bisschen geschmack rein bekommt dann
habe ich ihren mozzarella zum überbacken
kabinen schafskäse für innen reihen für
den geschmack und dann noch die kräuter
hier habe ich ein paar basilikumblätter
und hier noch frische minze und was
jetzt vergessen auch auszustellen
natürlich meine gewürze salz pfeffer und
chili
aber die habe ich gleich
zuerst mache jetzt diese füllung und
zwar schädliche stoffe die charlotte und
wirbels einfach zu klein und ich werde
jetzt vorher in der pfanne so ein
bisschen anbraten einfach damit dass
rost aroma von der zwiebel habt und das
ganze eben dann im ofen nicht mehr so
lange braucht das rezept kann man
übrigens deswegen auch richtig gut
vorbereiten
man kann nämlich die publisher füllen
und alles in so eine auflaufform geben
und einfach so kurz vor dem essen in den
ofen stecken und dann ist es eben gleich
fertig
dann gebe ich jetzt einen esslöffel
olivenöl in einer heißen pfanne und gibt
als die zwiebelwürfel mit dazu und die
werden jetzt einfach so in 23 minuten so
ein bisschen glasig gebraten bei
mittlerer stufe und ich kann die zeit
zwischendurch schon mal nutzen um mein
wasser aufzukochen will ich brauche auch
gleich ein paar und ich kann auf jeden
fall hier schon mal die paprika
vorbereiten und zwar halbiert die jetzt
einmal längs denn ich möchte so kleine
paprika schiffchen machen
sumann vorsichtig aufklappen und das
innere einfach rausnehmen
und die kann ich direkt in meine
auflaufform geben die muss ich aber
vorher vettel
denn das ist schon ein stein form da
wird ansonsten tritt leben deswegen kurz
mit olivenöl aus pinsel
und jetzt kann ich den couscous nehmen
und den einfach mit in die pfanne geben
und es war jetzt ungefähr
ich habe afrika im harz es ungefähr so
ein glas voll und jetzt nehme ich auch
ein glas voll wasser kochendes wasser
ist ganz schnell machen und gibt es da
einfach mit dazu
löschs eben damit ab und da gebe ich
jetzt den deckel drauf lass das ganze
bei mittlerer stufe so ungefähr eine
minute bis zwei quellen und kann in der
zeit nämlich schon mal hier meine oliven
und meine chilis kleinen haken die
oliven muss sich vorher so ein bisschen
entkernen und es kommt dann alles gleich
mit dazu
mittlerweile ist die sanierung wieder da
vom kindergarten und wie es sehen können
feiern dickert fasching samira alles was
bist du geschminkt tiger okay mein fuß
ist hier bereits gefallen
die oliven und chilis mit rein du darfst
auch gleich mit mir schneiden
ja ich hole ich geb dir gleichen messer
und dann gebe ich noch von diesem acker
als von dieser dieser paprika creme mit
rein einfach so ein teelöffel denn das
ist wirklich schade
und dann muss es jetzt erst mal kurz
verrührt werden mein herz ist übrigens
auch aus so einfach verrühren und wenn
ihr merkt der kuss kuss ist ein bisschen
zu trocken gibt einfach ein bisschen
wasser rein einfach damit etwas besser
vermischen kann
ja du darfst jetzt gleich nämlich den
käse schneiden
das darf sich an ihren einfach so in
kleine würfel okay jetzt die hälfte des
klein schneiden und ich kann schon mal
die füllung würzen mit pfeffer und
bisschen salz aber nicht sehr viel
denn der käse ist er schon salzig bei
mir kommt noch ein bisschen chili rein
aber nicht sehr viel denn ich habe schon
chilis drin und ich habe auch schon
dieses abo katrin es wird wieder ein
gericht für krämer mich gerne genau
bröselt es noch bisschen klein und ich
wollte noch was machen ihr wollt die
kräuter noch klein hacken
das mache ich noch kurz und dann sind
wir mit der zeitgleich fertig
und jetzt gebe ich die zwei oder drei
sachen einfach auch mit den couscous und
früher alles schön
dann müsste das einfach nur mal
abschmecken mit salz pfeffer eventuell
noch mal von dem paprika markt mit dazu
geben und dann kann das gleich befüllen
ich nehme jetzt doch noch ein bisschen
mehr käse einfach damit das ganze
würziger wird und ich brösel den jetzt
so ein bisschen rein was ich ein
bisschen probieren sie's einer den habe
ich jetzt heute zum ersten mal als wir
haben normalerweise immer so einen
anderen schafskäse den aus der dose
er schmeckt bitter wissel würziger ich
sitze nicht sogar also ich mag den
anderen mehr brillen genial
ja das halt geschmackssache also der es
wirklich intensiver im geschmack
ich finde so ein richtiger so ein
richtiger schafskäse halt also nicht
schlecht absolut nicht aber der andere
ist ein bisschen müde und ein bisschen
raus kommt als wenn jetzt fast das ganze
braucht so weiter und ich kann hier
schon mal anfangen zu befüllen und zwar
nehme ich mir jetzt immer so ein löffel
und befüllt ist einfach damit käme es
natürlich bisserl zu viel füllung
gemacht aber das macht nichts denn den
reis den reichen denn den couscous kann
man auch so ganz gut löffeln zum
beispiel morgen mittag dann ich mache
schon mal nichts kochen
jetzt gebe ich noch den mozzarella
darüber einfach damit es beim überbacken
jetzt so ist dann läuft es so ein
bisschen rein und schmeckt richtig gut
ich habe übrigens wie gesagt viel zu
viel füllung gemacht dass ich einfach
manchmal weil mir so wenn ich so spontan
was koche was ich vorher noch nicht
gemacht habe und es war ebenso ein
spontanes rezept und ich werde euch aber
die abgeänderten rezept angaben und
zutatenangaben einfach auf dem blog
veröffentlicht
lasst doch jetzt kommt es in den
backofen und zwar bei 200 grad für etwa
15 bis 20 minuten bis eben der
mozzarella schon geschmolzen ist und
einfach oft an der oberfläche so ein
bisschen anfängt dunkler zu werden jetzt
machst du auf vorsichtig zurückgehen
so sehen die überbackenen paprikas jetzt
aus und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal
wie wir die heute essen und wie ich sie
serviere und ich finde es schon richtig
lecker aus intel und ich es ganz gerne
zur reisgerichten zur bulgur gerichten
zu couscous gerichten es ich immer gern
joghurt und es geht bei uns eigentlich
echt fast immer zum mittagessen
weil joghurt bei uns früher daheim auch
immer mit bestandteil war von jedem
essen
ich schildere gleich gerade karotte und
ich nehme jetzt einfach so ein
stichfesten zehnprozentigen joghurt die
schmecken einfach im westen könnte aber
auch im normalen joghurt natürlich
nehmen
zum leichteren aber die sind einfach
schön cremig und wir haben einfach
wissen mac geschmack und den wird sich
jetzt so ein bisschen mit salz das ist
übrigens auch so was was ich einfach mal
gerne vom fernseher esse einfach joghurt
mit salz oder joghurt mit puderzucker
was ich mag es nicht somit also in
meiner familie gab es so viel ist schon
bei uns gibt es zu allem die sorge in
joghurt zu lassen und dann gebe ich da
einfach ein klecks drauf und dann kann
man das schön da rein dicken
hier noch ein plätzchen natürlich ein
bisschen großer teller aber ich mache
das jetzt einfach so gebe es einmal
gleich zwei schiffchen drauf und dann
ist es wirklich ein super tolles
hauptgericht ich würde sagen so diese
menge also mit den 500 gramm paprika als
hauptgericht wird für 23 personen
reichen aber wenn es als beilage dazu
reicht dann auf jeden fall für vier bis
fünf personen und ich lasse mir das
einfach gleich schmecken er sich noch zu
heiß zum probieren
ihr könnt auf jeden fall alles auch
austauschen möchte also oliven und
chilis und könnte mich alles mögliche
herum experimentieren und rein machen
und vielleicht habt ihr eigene
kreationen und ideen und könnt ihr mir
mal mitteilen
und da freue ich mich darüber und wir
sehen uns dann schon beim nächsten mal
wieder
wo gibt's das rezept auf eine schöne
köche rinn eine schöne kirche
danke